[Musica]
[Applauso]
non me l'aspettavate questa
come impariamo
proviamo a parlarne insieme ricordandoci
oggi
gli studi di un antropologo inglese
Gregory bateson il quale ci ha parlato
dei livelli di apprendimento
partiamo con l'apprendimento 1
raccogliere informazioni e aggregarle
l'apprendimento 1 è l'apprendimento
forse più semplice e avviene attraverso
due livelli principali la scuola e gli
adulti di riferimento
Impariamo ad esempio dagli adulti a dire
grazie buongiorno buonasera
impariamo che si nella strada si passa
con il verde ci si ferma con il rosso
non in tutte le città A dire il vero ma
questo è un altro discorso a scuola poi
impariamo altre informazioni uno due più
due fa quattro
impariamo la data di nascita di Leopardi
impariamo il teorema di Pitagora
poi noi stratifichiamo queste
informazioni 1 e ad un certo punto il
cervello fa uno scatto comincia a
trattenerne alcune e altri invece non
gli interessano più le lascio andare
ne ho avuto una prova Stamattina verso
le 6 quando accompagnato una delle mie
figlie a prendere il treno insieme a
delle amiche per raggiungere un'altra
amica in una ridente località marittima
della Romagna Ho provato a verificare se
i suoi apprendimenti uno fossero tutti
presenti per godersi la vacanza allora
le ho chiesto
sai qual è l'indirizzo dell'appartamento
che devi raggiungere risposta boh
Ti sei informato con le tue amiche
preparata per preparare i pasti Boh hai
un'idea dell'orario di ritorno di
martedì risposta
Bravissima avete vedete che avete
imparato anche voi con l'apprendimento
uno terzo quarto e ultima domanda ti
Stasera vai in discoteca assolutamente
sì Abbiamo il tavolo prenotato il PR si
chiama DJ Dave l'ho già spoilerato su
Instagram le informazioni uno che le
servono le erano molto chiare
dopo un po' di tempo che il cervello
stratifica informazioni è in grado di
fare il cosiddetto salto di livello e
andare all'apprendimento 2
imparare a imparare
questo salto di livello di cui abbiamo
parlato anche nell'introduzione permette
all'uomo di innovare
di Scoprire di essere creativo un
esempio molto classico è ciò che è
successo l'apollo 13 Houston abbiamo un
le informazioni uno non funzionano c'è
stato un guasto nella navicella tutto
che era stato perfettamente preparato
non funziona gli ingegneri di terra
ricevono i materiali presenti nella
navicella e sviluppano un apprendimento
due invento un ossigenatore
poi mandano le informazioni che dal 2
ritornano Uno agli Astronauti
permettendo loro di tornare vivi sulla
terra
ma non solo per gli ingegneri
aerospaziali è presente l'apprendimento
2 anche per noi ad esempio molti anni fa
sono Diversamente giovane per cui ho
fatto in tempo a vivere in un'epoca pre
Google Maps mi sono perso in una città
italiana meraviglioso di mare
non trovando il porto dove dovevo
recarmi per imbarcarmi sul traghetto ho
avuto un momento di smarrimento e ho
deciso di applicare l'informazione 1 che
mi aveva insegnato mia nonna Chiedi a un
passante quindi ho fermato un passante e
gli ho chiesto se gentilmente Poteva
dirmi dovere il porto questa persona mi
ha con grandissima gentilezza mi ha
detto così vede quella via in fondo a
sinistra Sì certo la prende la percorre
per due chilometri sempre dritto
arriverà proprio sulla via del mare
guardia a sinistra c'è il porto lei è
già arrivato e io ho chiesto ma però la
via che lei mi sta indicando C'è un
cartello con scritto divieto di transito
io non ci posso andare Ah sì Ma guardi
noi qua tutti sappiamo che ci possiamo
andare lo stesso
La domanda è voi ci sareste andati
e l'altra domanda è purtroppo io ci sono
andato No non ci sono andato perché sono
il disturbo Emiliano di personalità
quindi mi fido troppo dell'informazione
una e faccio fatica a passare le
informazioni due però comunque ho
imparato che devo fidarmi di più delle
persone e meno solo delle informazioni
uno
quindi posso parlare di un altro livello
di apprendimento l'apprendimento Zero
quello di cui si parla meno
l'apprendimento zero è imparare senza
che nessun insegni è l'apprendimento
implicito quello che gli scienziati
chiamano il nostro sistema dotato di
memoria il cervello ne è pieno nessuno
ci insegna a camminare
nessuno ci insegna a piangere nessuno ci
insegna a respirare noi lo sappiamo fare
anche correre e se precocemente veniamo
a contatto con l'acqua anche nuotare
l'apprendimento zero è quello che ci
ricorda che noi siamo nativi che
dobbiamo rispettare le leggi biologiche
perché parlano in noi che siamo connessi
al pianeta
e mai come oggi c'è bisogno di
ricordarcelo è importante
l'apprendimento Zero Assolutamente sì ce
lo ricorda tutti i giorni nel nostro
corpo se abbiamo paura ci tremano le
gambe
Se ci innamoriamo batte diversamente il
cuore Se qualcosa ci commuove i nostri
occhi perdono un liquido si chiamano
lacrime
e l'apprendimento zero e una di quelle
forme vibranti del nostro sapere che ci
permette di parlare dell'ultimo livello
di apprendimento il più complesso
apprendimento 3 l'uomo impara
attraverso lo stupore e la meraviglia
e le cose che nell'umanità più possono
promuovere lo stupore la meraviglia sono
l'arte e la bellezza
più noi siamo in grado di intercettare
di andare incontro all'arte della
Bellezza più Noi viviamo degli
apprendimenti 3 durante un apprendimento
3 noi scopriamo che la vita è sacra
Ma c'è qualcos'altro che può proporci
l'apprendimento 3 e sono piccolissime
cose della nostra quotidianità purché il
nostro occhio sia in grado di guardarle
con meraviglia nella più grande delle
piccolezze può esserci la più grande
forma di sacralità della vita stessa
il poeta è ride Luca è in grado di
raccontarci Che cos'è un apprendimento 3
con questa poesia che ora vi leggo
Considero valore ogni forma di vita la
neve la fragola La mosca Considero
valore il regno minerale l'assemblea
delle stelle
Considero valore il vino finché dura il
pasto un sorriso involontario la
stanchezza di chi non si è risparmiato
due vecchi che si amano Considero valore
tutte le ferite
Considero valore risparmiare acqua
riparare un paio di scarpe tacere in
tempo a correre un grido provare
gratitudine senza ricordare di che
Considero valore il viaggio del
vagabondo la clausura della monaca La
pazienza del condannato qualunque colpa
sia
Considero valore l'uso del verbo amare e
l'ipotesi che esista un creatore
Ebbene per concludere una storia
una storia vera
dieci anni fa in questa terra c'è stato
il terremoto
e racconta la storia di un amico di un
ragazzo che dice anni fa si trova in una
condizione particolare come tutti noi
si trova in mezzo a tutte le persone
intorno a lui che hanno perso la casa e
il lavoro e impara un apprendimento uno
una parola nuova inagibile
ed è disperato perché i suoi genitori
sono già un po' avanti con l'età e nel
passare dei giorni mentre dormono in
macchina vorrebbe dargli una tenda per
dormire ma non la trova le hanno
comprate tutte
ma non c'è stata solo l'onda della terra
dieci anni fa c'è stata un'altra onda
l'onda della solidarietà
organizzata dalle associazioni la
Protezione Civile e disorganizzata
un'onda umana di persone che hanno
portato delle cose cibo
vicinanza materiali progetti e questa
quel ragazzo riceve quella tenda in dono
e può finalmente mettere a rifare i suoi
genitori
poi l'emergenza passa ricostruiamo Siamo
operosi siamo Emiliani abbiamo ricevuto
tantissimo con tenacia e speranza
passano 10 anni quel ragazzo ha
dimenticato la tenda nel garage ed è
diventato un uomo
e nel marzo di quest'anno una notte non
riesce a dormire
i suoi apprendimenti Zero sono alterati
il cuore batte molto forte non sa perché
le sue gambe vogliono muoversi e non sa
perché so solo che a un certo punto nel
cuore della notte si mette in viaggio fa
1500 chilometri arriva al confine più
estremo della Polonia
e vede centinaia forse migliaia di
persone che sono come lui dieci anni fa
non hanno casa non hanno lavoro forse
non hanno più la libertà
e vede ancora una volta l'onda della
solidarietà e lui ne fa parte
cammina Cerca non sa cosa Cerca ancora
non lo sa poi trovo una donna per caso
con due bambini si guardano
e lui capisce in quel momento che ha
quella donna deve dare questa tenda e
capisce solo in quel momento perché è lì
perché in quel momento mentre dona la
tenda e si abbracciano sente sciogliersi
Dentro di lui
il nudo della gratitudine
la morsa della gratitudine che
sciogliendosi diventa
l'abbraccio della comunità
diventa il non sentirsi soli diventa una
forma molto raffinata di apprendimento 3
e in quel momento quelle due persone che
non sanno nemmeno i loro nomi e non
hanno un linguaggio comune
imparano la gratitudine la vicinanza e
che la vita è sacra Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]